die cd wieder alles lug herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video schadenbearbeitung bestellt uns
war das cyberbike hierbei setzt sich
genau wisst was das ist es ist von
künstler namens denn hier man ganz
kurzer ausschnitt aus dem song von denen
die drei jungs aber ein neues album
rausgebracht und dahingehend auch ein
video wo sie erklärt haben was passiert
ist daraus sage ich auch mal ganz kurzen
ausschnitt 321 jetzt wissen wir alle was
gemeint ist
denn ein rad wie die cyber punk
limitiert inklusive cd m und maske usb
stick und poster gutschein
das ist also alles drin deswegen heute
morgen bei mir an und erst mal danke
amazon deshalb überall irgendwelche
macken und schrammen ich würde sagen wir
machen das ganze jetzt zusammen auf und
zwar kann ich mir die sachen raus holen
da ist es das ist alles dieses pack hat
mich 40 euro gekostet
red wisst ihr was man sich von 40 euro
alles kaufen kann 40 cheeseburger oder
13 döner oder auch ein rudel
aber gut ich meinen da sind auf dem
album natürlich auch ein paar tricks
drauf und ich habe irgendwie ein
mundschutz und usb stick und irgendwie
noch so ein ding also es wird schon
irgendwie gerechtfertigt sein
ich habe es mir auch nicht unfreiwillig
bestellt haben wir schauen uns das ganze
jetzt mal an sind jetzt rausgefallen ein
code ein lösbares 31 dritte 2017 löse
den code auf der rückseite auf ein
dolmetsch wird kommen und halbach ich
trinke ein poster mensch dann sind die
40 euro gerechtfertigt weiß nicht was
das heißen soll also das ist quasi das
erst was daraus gemacht dass es so einen
korb mit dem ich mir jetzt irgendwo ein
poster holen kann
dann haben wir noch das hier das ist
irgendwie sondern achte scc drin die cdu
die schreiber
von hier oben deutschen cd ich würde
diese cd ist echt gerne mein laptop
entschieden allerdings habe ich kein
cd-laufwerk meine haut dort auch kein
cd-laufwerk mein handy erst recht nicht
das heißt ich glaube die cdu brauche ich
nicht nur die cd wieder cds drin aber
jedoch ein gelbes büchlein sogar
instruction dawns capital album patience
reales wenn ich sehe dass in letzter
zeit mega häufig an irgendwelchen wenden
dass da so sachen quasi dem muster
irgendwie an die wand geklatscht wurden
hier haben wir glaube ich irgendwie die
tüte und ja wir wieder solche sachen
also das haben die echt coole macht
diese ganze grafiken hier nochmal
danksagungen an bestimmte leute
ich habe das video hier probelaufs
nächste als bei den danksagungen sind
echt ein paar komische namen ball
irgendwie pablo paradies sich haben
einen drogenboss hippie weil sie ein
kleiner vor skippy denkt in seinem urin
pamir sind auch echt nice in die matthew
taylor oder deren brady ich weiß nicht
ob die die nager dazu geschrieben haben
weil die sich gut anhören aber das
büchlein ist auf jeden fall weiß wir
können das kleine buch wieder hier rein
schieben in die kasse dann hatten wir
hier die cd drinnen die haben jetzt auch
schon raus genommen also das herz ganz
kurzes wort von mir zu der mucke also es
ist jetzt nicht das erste mal dass ich
irgendetwas mitbekommen von diesem hype
wie die album also ich hab das mir schon
irgendwie vor fünf sechs tagen bei
spotify runtergeladen angehört ich will
hier kein held kassieren von
irgendwelchen fanbase von den dreien
aber ich finde die mucke nicht nice also
ich weiß nicht ich sehe dass dahinter
eine menge arbeit steckt weil die beats
echt hammer krass sind so die texte da
muss man auch erstmal drauf kommen aber
ich bin halt er
der uk haus check-in bass mensch
deswegen kann ich mit seiner mutter halt
überhaupt nichts anfangen das geht nicht
gegen die vocal das ist einfach meine
freie meinung ich finde das einzige
coole die doch dem album ist wie heißt
er denn noch mal party niklaus das mit
note future noch kritischer parat wie
der typ genau heißt aber das bin ich
jetzt das beste lied auf dem album mit
den anderen lieder kann ich nicht so
viel anfangen aber dass in der du
verschiedene geschmäcker also jeder der
jetzt rum hated ist einfach nicht
tolerant gegenüber verschiedene
musikgeschmäcker das haben jetzt auch in
dem cybertech und zwar einmal einem und
maske und einen usb stick
den kann ich jetzt nämlich mal ganz kurz
rausnehmen das ist nämlich der einzige
grund warum ich mir das album bestellt
habe ich habe den usb stick leider
verlegt wahrscheinlich später der hat
der ist obermann steckt ihn raus dann
steht wieder rein leuchtet damit man
weiß was drinsteht usb stick hidrive
free de und bad saarow oder ist ja drauf
als allererstes dann würde ich sofort
wir hoffen dass sie zufrieden stellt was
du hier vorfinden wie es der usb stick
leute auf den usb-stick sind alle
versionen der songs enthalten die wir
während der produktion des albums
abgespeichert haben also quasi die basis
nach jeder session so kann man die
entstehung des ganzen nochmal schritt
für schritt nachvollziehen und sehen
wann genau an welchen spezifischen
fragen gearbeitet haben zusätzlich haben
noch einige video aufnahmen die während
des entstanden sind in die ewigen ordner
gepackt will dann skizzen die die
entstehung des artworks erkennbar machen
sind auch mit dabei
brix und ein paar extra infos ebenso
eigentlich haben wir so ziemlich alles
zusammengesucht was irgendwie
interessant sein könnte klingt nicht
einfach durch macht dann eingespielt
davon viel spaß dabei schauen wir mal
die videoaufnahmen an
das cool also ohne spaß weiß ich so ein
bisschen so ein behind the scenes habe
ich also noch auf keinem album gesehen
dass einfach locker sein usb stick
beilag wo alle möglich dateien drauf
sind also ist schillig ist mutig aber
ist neu ist aber kombi nun zur
wichtigsten frage und zwar wie viel
speicher hat dieser usb stick gigabyte
dvd zu sehen
danke jungs kommen wir nun zur letzten
sache die der haut mit ran gegangen war
und zwar einem und maske das ist meine
ich sie dir aber auch immer auf warum er
die haut hat weiß ich nicht
auf der rückseite von diesen cybertech
steht die limitierte einrad wie die
mutmaßte findest du direkt im pack mit
ihrer bist du all unterwegs und eines
work werte steigen ins unermessliche
jungs wie alt seid ihr ich bin vor allem
so ein richtig guter unboxing kanal
überhaupt nicht vorgelegt was auf der
verpackung steht der kleine drache bild
steht ihr drauf juni 23 den die fans
wieder weg deshalb eine limitierte
sonderedition unseres neuen albums ein
referee die mit ein paar extra features
wenn du den beiliegenden code in unserem
shop einlöst kommt das limitierte ein
haltbares dass das ja es war alles schon
kommen wir nun zu dieser maske
ich denke mal dass das hier unten
wirklich für das kind ist damit man sich
dass sie oben einen gott ich kann nicht
reden
das teilt schwingt nach 10 t kleben und
zumindest bei mir sitzt es auch extrem
locker also ich kann mir das jetzt auch
irgendwie so in england ist schnallt
sich echt nicht fest also ist die ganze
zeit irgendwie unter aurich kommt
vorstellen freunde bei mario jetzt ist
nice deren das teil fühlt sich echt nice
an
in vier tagen ist elfter elfter
ich glaube ich mache mit irgendwem
kostüm
also ich selber kann das jetzt
wahrscheinlich nicht so richtig
beurteilen aber meiner meinung nach ist
ist sie sind so ein bisschen qualitativ
minderwertig aber ich habe keine ahnung
ich denke die sind auch die ersten die
gegen die sonne dinge ist jährigen die
produziert haben aber wenn man das dann
auch auf falsch und wenn man das teil
auch selbst fühlt sich das wirklich nice
an also ich hätte jetzt nicht gedacht
das ist so angenehm ist und wunsch zu
tragen hat dann hier unten durch das ist
megageil ich feiere das gar nicht übel
hat mich bisher echt nur bei den usb
stick befreundeten jungs wenn ihr das
ihr seht nichts gegen euch aber ich habe
der musik wirklich nicht so viel
anfangen es trifft einfach nicht zu
meinen persönlichen geschmack habe in
dieser wunsch jetzt echt nice ohne spaß
ich überlege mir irgendwie sonnengelb
lösung zu holen die mit überzustülpen
dann will ich irgendwie walz atomen
chemiker oder so geht also jetzt motto
so und karneval vor seinen müllsack
sodann meister sondern atomzeichen drauf
dann nämlich von der mundschutz masken
breakdancer hey hier ist luca steht luca
aus dem schnitt ja ich muss eine ganz
kurze anmerkung machen weil ich habe
dieses video gerade geschnitten und mir
ist aufgefallen dass jetzt vielleicht
einige fan gehört oder allgemeinen leute
die die mucke feiern denken dass ich ein
totaler eltern von denen befinde ich
nicht kommt runter falls ihr hoch
gekommen sein
ich habe die drei eigentlich glaube ich
alle schon mal irgendwie persönlich
getroffen zwar nie mit denen jetzt eine
stunde gelabert also ich würde mich
jetzt nicht als freund von denen bisher
denn ich weiß einfach dass das korrekte
leute sind ich feiere einfach nur die
mucke nicht so ganz weiß einfach nicht
meine musikrichtung jeder feiert
irgendwie adele und ihrem
sieg ich feiere die musik auch nicht so
krass das macht mich noch lange nicht
zum hater von adele solange mich dies
auch nicht zu einem hält davon denn
jetzt macht ja ich hoffe ihr wisst was
ich meine und das ganze ist natürlich
noch humor ich habe das ding bestimmt
nicht nur bestellt ein usb stick bringt
sondern weil ich wirklich eigentlich die
idee cool finden sonst ein perfekt
machen
ja jetzt kommt das auto das was ihr vom
video meine damen und herren ich hoffe
es hat euch gefallen wenn sie es getan
hat schreibt der fachmann kommentar und
in die kommentare was nicht gefallen hat
bla bla bla bla bla
was mache ich mit meinem leben
eigentlich würde der raw datei gerade
bei satten 27 minuten das heißt ich
stehe seit einer halben stunde vor der
kammer und quatsch wenn wir wirklich
etwas dran sein sollte dann schreib mal
der erde
die kommentare dann sehe ich wenn ihr
dem start dieses video bis zum ende
geschaut hat versteht ihr findet hier
einen smiley eingeblendet wenn ihr
darauf könnt ihr meinen kanal abonnieren
ich lade öfters hoch her nicht so viele
tun das schon okay ich kann es mir nicht
erklären wir auf jeden fall nicht hier
findet ihr das video von gestern
verlegen das ist frage antwort video
kommentare beantworten
michael h